not going to be removed from office but
about trying to take the Senate and so
I'm proud of my members for resisting
the temptation to go down that path for
also preventing what the second strategy
was it was pretty clear the Democrats if
they couldn't win this wanted to
embarrass the Chief Justice try to drag
him into this Maelstrom and the way that
could have been done obviously was with
a 50/50 vote where he would have been
accused had he chosen not to rule which
of course I can't imagine he would have
but it's pretty clear that would have
dragged the Supreme Court right into the
middle of the mails from as well so
we've reached the conclusion I think
this was a thoroughly political exercise
from the beginning to the end and the
final irony of it all is the speaker was
right in the beginning because here we
are today in a position to judge the
political impact of this since it all
started about politics how did it end
about politics the president has his
highest approval rating since he's been
in office I can tell you as a poll
watcher who's looking at polls and
certain Senate races every one of our
people in tough races every one of them
is in better shape today than they were
before the impeachment trial started so
I'm not sitting here predicting what
will be the biggest issue in November
but I can tell you this I can tell you
this right now this is a political loser
for them they initiated it they thought
this is a great idea and at least for
the short term it has been a colossal
political mistake
con dog said his inappropriate
shape or dismal Kasich said one of them
of course today so he would vote to
convict the President on abuse of power
Mitt Romney did you why is it okay for
the president to ask another foreign
country to investigate right now man ooh
I've been responding to you for years
and you know that what I'm here to talk
about today is the political impact of
this we've completed it we're listening
to their arguments we voted it's in the
rearview mirror and I think what's
appropriate now is to way since it all
began for political reasons the
political impact of it and I think it's
pretty clear what I've already said it's
where we are right now yeah room in the
Republican Party for someone who votes
for the president's conviction well I
was surprised and disappointed but I
still think that we had great team work
on this and I think we're in a good
position going into our Senate races and
the presidential race with regard to
this issue there may be plenty of other
issues between now and November but I
think we're in pretty good shape right
now yes already talking about next steps
appealing John Bolton is there a serious
political price to pay they don't move
on after impeachment well you know I've
watched these impeachments over the
these investigations over the years by
both sides I really think the American
people are more likely to focus at this
point and for the rest of the year
on what kind of shape is the country and
how are you feeling about things are you
better off as President Reagan put it
are you better off now than you were
four years ago
yeah I think the investigations will go
on that's sort of what Congress does it
we've done it when we were in the
majority and there was a Democratic
president they've done it I wouldn't
expect that to stop hmm I think in the
end it's not likely to have much of an
impact on any of the races the
presidential
the Senate races yeah just to follow up
on Garrett's question there is is
calling for Mitt Romney to be expelled
from the Republican Conference is there
any chance that Mitt Romney is expelled
from the Republican Conference as a
result of his vote to convince yeah look
I was surprised and disappointed but we
have much work to do for the American
people and I think Senator Romney has
been largely supportive of who most
everything we've tried to accomplish
what's why service reluctance to engage
specifically on the issue of the
president's conduct or was it acceptable
for president Trump to ask the leader of
Ukraine to investigate the Biden's and
subsequently hold up military aid that
specific question I'm sure you were
paying close attention but that's
exactly what we've been talking about
for the last three weeks
yeah I think the relationship is fine
but adopting the Clinton rules didn't
serve his purpose so let's go back to
what he was trying to achieve he's very
forthright about it we had a discussion
before we began the trial he wanted to
guarantee at least some number of
witnesses before we started I felt that
our best interest and the best interest
of the country was served by listening
to the arguments and going through the
questioning period before we got to the
question of witnesses because we might
or might not conclude at that point that
we needed any witnesses because we had a
mountain of evidence headed our way that
they were referred to repeatedly which
was the best argument against additional
witnesses I mean how many times did they
have to say the case was conclusive of
what was the line proven or approved or
overwhelming now when you listen to
those kind of arguments being made by
the managers you scratch your head and
say now really you
we need to hear more so that was the
difference we didn't we weren't angry
about it he was trying to achieve an
outcome that he sought helped him win
the Senate
I felt that Clinton president made more
sense not only for the country but for
us yeah a little bit more about why it
was so important to you not just to make
sure the president was acquitted but
that you had a United conference which
you almost had voting to put the
President and how fear of the Republican
base for your members that are in some
tough States may have helped make that
decision well first I obviously hoped
that the result in the Senate would be
similar or exactly the same as a result
in the house and I think the message
there is don't do partisan impeachment
which remembers what to pray what the
speaker said and she was initially
correct about what she said sometime
back we don't want this to become
routine all of us looked at a number of
things the founders said when they put
impeachment in the Constitution and they
really were concerned about it becoming
a kind of routine effort based on policy
differences or personality differences
sound familiar
I mean the main thing that drove Andrew
Johnson's impeachment they just didn't
like him sound familiar
I mean that's the kind of thing it seems
to me the founders did not want to
happen that we'd get in the routine of
doing this all the time because we had a
policy difference or a personality
difference so I'm glad it ended the way
it did I hope the message to the House
of Representatives don't do this again
we don't have any dog houses here the
most important vote is the next vote
Cheryl
it's agenda going forward and given the
obvious animosity between the speaker
and the president at last night's State
of the Union speech do you think that
this Congress can really accomplish
anything legislatively with this White
House my biggest problem is
accomplishing it with this House of
Representatives as you all know we had
we were pretty different approaches to
America's problems between the house and
the Senate I think we've got a chance to
do some more business I certainly hope
so we're looking at infrastructure we're
looking at a parks bill we're looking at
land and water conservation
there are even in the midst of the
election some things that I think we can
do together and even though several of
you have completely bought into the
notion that we're somehow totally
dysfunctional I would point you back to
the end of last year there were a number
of dramatic bipartisan accomplishments
in the overall spending bills at the end
of the year admittedly I didn't move
across the floor and independently but
in that bill were a huge number of
priorities for both sides and those only
get negotiated on a bipartisan basis so
I don't buy the notion that the Congress
is dysfunctional we have some big
differences I mean look at what the
House passes and look at what we do we
do have some big differences but we'll
get some more work done for the American
people on the things that we can agree
on and then they'll settle all of this
in November and decide who they want to
lead the country going forward I'm sorry
I can't hear you the Equal Rights
Amendment resolution from Senator
Murkowski and Collins to ratify that
constitutional amendment is that
something you'd be open to putting on
the floor to ratify what oh I haven't
thought about that I'm personally not a
supporter but I haven't thought about it
yeah
when the Republican Party the Biden's
look I don't tell the committee chairman
what to look at is one of you suggested
earlier the house is probably still an
investigatory business I can only
suggest that the Senate could choose to
do that as well
but we don't have a dictatorship over in
the Senate and I don't I don't instruct
the committee chairman as to what to
take a look at yes so you have avoided
answering the question that the new
asked several times including twice
today would you like to make it a third
time
no you just praised your members for
taking difficult votes in a political
environment it's perfectly reasonable
question to ask whether or not the
president's actions are appropriate yeah
I think that's what we've just dealt
with for three weeks three weeks we've
listened we voted we've had a number of
internal meetings to discuss all of this
which you all ended up knowing a good
deal about and writing about it's time
to move on this decision is been made as
far as I'm concerned it's in the
rearview mirror and the consequences of
it in terms of the future are up to the
voters of the country to decide who they
want to lead the government for the next
for and in our case that kept with the
class secures I'm gonna take one more if
there is one what do you make of the
fact that the House vote was bipartisan
against the impeachment and in the
Senate you've had the opposite with
Senator Romney being the only Jew yeah I
think you can put I think they're pretty
clearly party lined both ways I think
that's what you can take out of it
pretty much party line in both
both chambers thanks a lot everybody